[Music]
hi everyone thank you very much for
coming along
I'm Andrew I'm a software engineer on
the exoplayer team and I'm mark and
developer advocate for Android media so
in today's session we're hoping to
demonstrate how you can build really
really fully featured media playback
functionality into apps using quite
little code using exoplayer and to do
that we're going to guide you through
the process of building two applications
we're going to start by focusing on the
video use case we're going to build a
simple video player app that will play
an mp4 stream then we're going to show
you how to insert ads alongside that
video content then we're going to shift
our focus to audio we're going to show
you how to play audio in a background
service we're going to show you how to
integrate with Android media sessions
and finally we're going to take a look
at some new functionality we've we've
recently released for downloading media
for offline playback so like last year
we're hoping to have a mixture of some
introductory content and also some
coverage of slightly more tricky use
cases so hopefully there's something for
everyone and with that in mind I'm going
to start by saying a bit about what
exoplayer is for anyone who hasn't used
the library before ok clicker doesn't
seem to you're working next slide great
and so exoplayer is an application-level
media player that means that you choose
which version of exoplayer you'd like to
use and then you bundle the player
implementation into your application as
a dependency and what that gives you is
consistent playback functionality across
all different Android versions and
across all different devices exoplayer
works from API 16 that's Android jelly
bean upwards so with that you can reach
more than 99% of active devices the
project is open source is hosted on
github and we have an active community
there and you can file issues with
feature requests bugs and you can even
send us pull requests exoplayer is also
quite widely used both within google
applications like the YouTube app for
Android and also in Google Play Movies
it's also quite widely used in the wider
android community
and there are actually over 200,000
applications on the Playstore that are
using exoplayer and the team's always
really excited to see the kind of great
products that you're all building using
exoplayer since the last years talk
we've been working hard on both
stability and performance improvements
behind the scenes but also on some brand
new features and in doing that exoplayer
is gradually evolving into quite a
fully-featured solution for media
playback so here's some of the
highlights of the features that we've
added over the past year there's much
too much to go into detail on here but I
would encourage you to check out the
release notes in the root directory of
our github project where you can find
full details of all of the changes
included in each new release of the
player in today's talk we're just going
to cover a few highlights including
support for downloading media as I
mentioned and also support for player
notifications okay I think that's enough
on the slides let's get on with some
live coding and for each of these two
apps our video app and our audio app our
starting point will be a mostly empty
project because we want to show you as
much of the interesting code as possible
but we're going to provide a link to a
branch on our github project where you
can check out the code afterwards if you
want to look at things in a bit more
detail okay mark are you ready to do
some furious typing yes I am great okay
if we can switch to the laptop please
our starting point is a mostly empty
project as I mentioned and we're going
to make a video player app where we
start playing the stream as soon as the
app comes into the foreground and then
we stop playing the stream when we go
into the background and to do that the
first step is going to be to add a
dependency on the exoplayer core library
and this provides the main interface to
the player that you can use to control
playback from within code as you can see
marks added a dependency on the core
library with the version two point eight
point zero which is the new release that
we've done this week he's also add a
dependency added a dependency on the
optional UI module this provides some
customizable high-level UI components
which you can put into your applications
for things like showing a video player
interview that's player view which we're
going to use today and it also provides
playback control of you and some
the components and these are all very
customizable so you can change which
icons you're using you can customize the
layouts and so on so you can see that
mark has added a player view which is
going to fill the activity and he's
given it an identifier player underscore
view so we'll be able to access it from
code now if we switch over to our main
activity we can see in our on create
method we can get access to that view
using find view by ID and once we've got
access to that view then the next step
we're going to take is to actually
initialize the player okay so once we've
got our player view in a field
let's override the on start method and
in on start we're going to initialize
the player to initialize the player
we're going to use a static method on
the exoplayer factory called new simple
instance this is going to give us a
simple exoplayer instance now it might
sound like simple exoplayer is only for
really basic stuff but actually simple
exit players are recommended way of
integrating at the moment because it
provides it does lots of things for you
for example handling the lifecycle of
the surface holder for video output you
can see also that we're passing in as
well as a context a track selector
implementation in this example we're
going to use a default track selector
but this is an example of a pattern
which is very common in EXO players API
where you pass in a dependency of a
component in this case we're passing in
a default track selector but you could
pass in your own track selector
implementation if you wanted to have
much more control over how track
selections working so Mark's already
gone ahead and he's bound the player to
the player view so that their players
output is going to appear in that
particular view ok so the next step is
to tell exoplayer what we want to play
and for that there are really two parts
the first one is to provide a factory
for data sources data sources tell
exoplayer how to load data for example
using a particular HTTP stack or loading
files from the local device in this
example we're using a default data
source which is suitable for many use
cases it provides loading for HTTP URLs
files from the local disk assets and
resources bundled into your apk and so
on but if you wanted to for example use
the chromium Network stack
then you could use a cronut datasource
Factory okay so that's the first part of
telling exoplayer what to load the next
part is specifying a media source your
choice of media source is going to
depend on the type of media you're
trying to play in this example we're
going to be playing an mp4 so we're
going to use an extractor media source
which supports formats like mp4 mp3
Matroska and so on if you wanted to play
- or HLS or smooth streaming streams
then you would use the corresponding
media sources for those different
formats and you can see that marks
passing in the URI thar mp4 when he's
creating the media source okay once
we've got our media source now we just
need to prepare the player to start
offering data so we'll pass that to the
prepare method then we're going to call
set play when ready to tell the player
that as soon as it transitions from the
buffering state to the ready state then
playback should begin automatically
having done that all that remains is to
clean up when the activity goes into the
background so we'll override on destroy
sorry on stop okay and in that we're
going to clear the player reference on
the player view and then we're going to
release the player okay and this is kind
of the the minimum code you need just to
play a video stream let's go ahead and
deploy that to the device now and if we
could switch to the phone please
hopefully you haven't missed out
anything so when when the applications
been installed on the voice the device
you should see the video starts to play
automatically and you can see that if
you tap on the video views you get so
normal devices simple playback controls
pretty much what you'd expect from a
video player up so you can pause and
resume you can seek around and so on
okay let's let's now switch back to the
laptop please so let's imagine we've
launched our video app and if you switch
to the laptop please we've launched our
video app and now we'd like to think
about how we're going to monetize our
content by showing ads this is extremely
easy to do with exoplayer we've recently
added an IMA extension which makes this
very easy
so exoplayer extensions are wrappers
around external functionality that make
it very easy to use with exoplayer in
this case the IMA extension is a wrapper
around the interactive media ads SDK
which provides support for loading XML
add tags in vast and V map formats which
is a standard format for information
about ads so we're going to be using
that to load ads and then we're going to
insert it with it within the content in
our player so we're going to create a
ads loader which is a we're going to use
an ima ads loader which is the object
that's provided by the IMA extension
this is going to take the context and an
ad tag URI which is the URI of an XML
document specifying what ads to play
we're in the content so we're going to
create that ads loader in oncreate and
then we're going to release it in on
destroy the reason we're using on create
and on destroy is that that ads loader
contains information about which ads
have already been played so we want to
make sure that if the app goes into the
background and comes back into the
foreground we don't show the same ads
multiple times okay and as I mentioned
before media sources are how we tell
exoplayer what to play and in order to
play ads we use the predictably named
ads media source so we're going to
create an ads media source we'll pass in
the content media source that we want to
play we'll pass in a data source factory
which is going to be used to load data
for playing the ads we'll fast in the
ads loader and finally we'll pass in a
view group that's on top of the player
and that's going to be used to show any
user interface associated with ads like
for example the skip button and building
an ads media source out of a content
media source like this is an example of
media source composition and this is
something that you can do with exoplayer
and we'll see some more examples of it
later when we look at playlists okay so
we refer the player with the ads media
source and then we should be good to go
so you can see we've hopefully hopefully
this will work
if we can switch to the phone we were
able to add support for playing ads with
maybe 10 or so lines of code and
actually this this way of integrating
the IMA SDK gives a really good user
experience because exoplayer
knows about which ads are coming up in
the future
and that means that it's going to be
able to buffer the content in advance
and that adds it can buffer their ads in
advance to give you seamless transitions
between ads and content so as you saw we
had a pre-roll ad at the beginning and
now the time bar has little yellow
markers it's just showing us their
positions of ads within the content and
exoplayer is taking care of all of the
difficulty of loading the ads and
buffering everything behind the scenes
for us okay so that's I'll play back and
now over some arcs to talk a bit about
audio yeah thank you Andrew so far we
focus on video only so let's switch to
another application and look a little
bit into audio playback audio playback
is a little bit more challenging because
we want to enable the user to put our
application into the background and use
another application and audio should
still keep playing in the background for
this we are going to use the so called
foreground service it's called a
foreground service because we need to
attach a notification to this service
and this notification is in the
foreground it's visible to the user so
the user is always aware we are doing
some work in the background
since Oreo such a know such a foreground
service is a mandatory requirement if we
don't put our service into the
foreground the system will kill our
service and the application crashes so
let's have a look at the starting point
of our foreground service and let's
switch back to the laptop please yes we
see here we have this audio player
service which extends from the service
we have already overridden the oncreate
method where we put the code from our
video sample where we initialize and
prepare the player with a single media
item in only stroy will release our
resources and finally in own stored
commands we return step start sticky so
the service is not immediately destroyed
and we can explicitly terminate our
service when we are ready when we are
finished with audio playback the service
also already registered in the manifest
we have this simple service element
which just points to our audio player
service clause and finally we need to
have a way to store our service we do
this in the main activity in the own
create method
of the mainactivity here we create an
intent pointing to our audio player
service and then we use a static method
of the exoplayer library which starts
the service in foreground according to
the to the API level so now let's go
back into the audio player service again
and let's change this code a little bit
of the very initialize our player
because for audio we don't want to only
support playing a single media item we
want to support playlists so the user
can can move to the next or to the
previous item Oh can't just let the
players play one item after the other
with EXO player we are using a
concatenating media source to implement
playlists these concatenating media
source just joins together a number of
media sources and place them callously
and without rebuffering in between so we
achieve a pretty nice user experience
for platfor do play back the
concatenating media source also allows
us to dynamically change the playlists
so we can add and remove media sources
while the player is playing or we can
even move the currently playing item in
our playlist while the player is playing
that's pretty neat so Andrew already
started to iterate over our song whose
area and for each sample we get a URI we
again are going to create an extractor
media source but then we add this
extract a media source to our
concatenating media source in the end we
prepare our player with this
concatenating media source and we are
already done we are now supporting
playlists with gapless play gapless
which play gapless lee and without repo
rebuffering so but now let's have a look
at our service again and make it a
proper foreground service we've already
said we need to attach a notification to
our foreground service and for this we
are going to use the player notification
service in what manager the player
notification manager will not only
create the notification but it will keep
it nicely in sync with the state of the
player so each time the player state
changed the manager will update an
application
and post it to our driver again we use a
static method to create display or
notification manager and we need to pass
a couple of arguments which first we
need to pass the context then we need to
pass the channel ID which identifies our
channel to which we post our
notification the next parameter is a
string identifier which which gives us a
localized name for our channel this is
the name which shows up in the settings
dialog where our user maybe want to mute
our notification channel and then next
parameter is a notification ID to
identify identify our notification and
finally we need to pass a so called
media description adapter the manager
will use our adapter to get information
about the currently playing item so each
time the notification is rebuilt the
adapter is called to get this
information so we see that for each of
those callbacks the player instance is
passed to the method so we can use this
player this player to get the current
window index the current window index
gives us the index to pick our sample
out of our samples arrey which is kind
of the playlist we return the title to
get a content title then we have a
pretty similar method where we just
return the description which is a longer
text which is displayed in the context
in a notification and finally we also
provide a bitmap to make our
notification a little bit nicer we just
use a convenient method of our examples
to get such a bitmap for each of our
samples finally we also need to provide
a pending intent this pending intent is
fired when the user taps on the
notification and we want to get the user
back to our application in this thin our
example to the main HDV the activity so
we create and intent pointing to our
main activity and then we wrap this
intent into a pending intent which we
are using with the static method get
activities on the pending intent here
again a couple of arguments the context
as the first argument then a request
code which is 0 in our case we are not
going to use it in our sample then they
tend pointing to our main active
and finally a flag to tell the system to
update any pending intents already in
the queue so now we have this player
notification manager we now also need to
register a notification listener this
listener makes our service aware of the
lifecycle of our notification it has two
methods so we register this notification
in a listener which is an anonymous
clause in this case the first method or
notification started is called when the
notification is initially created here
we are now passed those two arguments to
the start foreground service and this is
now the moment where our service is
officially at foreground service we are
now safe the system is not going to kill
our service anymore the next method then
is called when the notification is
counseled here it just stopped self our
service because we want to terminate the
service finally we also need to register
the player we set the player if the set
player method on the notification
manager so the notification manager can
sync the player state to the
notification so that's about it we also
need to clean up in the ondestroy method
here we just lull to set their player
instance again so we don't leak a player
a player reference when the service is
being destroyed so now please change
back to the phone and if we done
everything right we should now be able
to hear the playlist playing in our
service the application comes up we see
the notification in the drawer
it's playing and let's have a look at a
notification in a drawer we see here the
information which it comes from our
adapter we can use the playback controls
to control playback we can pause or
start again we can skip to the next item
and if we tap on the notification it
gets us back to the application so fine
so as a next step we have seen now that
this notification contains information
about the current item and about the
state and it lets the user control the
media playback what if we want to expose
these functionality to external
application good let's go to it and
there can be go back to the slides
please here Google assistant for example
may want to yeah if you know here we go
Google assistant for example wants to
allow the user to use voice commands to
control media playback and with auto or
various let's use a remote control
remote control a media application and
browse in a media catalog of our
application the android framework has a
solution for this because we essentially
need to provide three things to let
external application participate in
media playback first we need to expose
the playback state this is two things
like the player state itself the current
media item or the playlist with which we
prepared our player second we need to be
able to retrieve playback commands from
external command external application so
we can execute those commands on our
player instance and third we need to
provide ways to browse in our media
catalog the android framework provides a
solution for this it provides the media
session and the Media Browser service we
are not going into the detail of the
Media Browser service because we don't
have time for this but we let me look at
the media session which allows us to
expose the playback state and retrieve
playback commands in our code sample we
are going to use that media session
Connect
which is part of the mediasession
extension of the exoplayer library this
mediasession connector synchronizes the
player state with the state of the media
session and retrieves commands from the
media session so let's change again back
to the laptop please so we can see how
we can do this in code we are again in
the oncreate method of our player of our
audio player service and we are now
going to create an instance of a media
session session compart we assign it to
a field we just call the
mediasessioncompat constructor with the
context and an identifier which is the
media which is just a string then we
immediately set our media session had to
active by call back passing through to
the set active method now as a first
step we want to make the player
notification manager aware of our
session and we pass the token to the
player notification manager so we can
enhance the media style notification and
provide an organ artwork for our lock
screen of our device but now we are
going to create such a media session
connection we call the constructor and
we just pass the media session to the
connector so he has access to the
session we said we want to synchronize
our playlist with the cue of the media
session so external application know
what items we are having in our playlist
for this we are going to use a timeline
view navigator the timeline is the
internal representation of the playlist
after the player has been prepared so
there are as many windows in our
timeline as we have items in our
playlist so with this we can use the
window index which is the parameter
which is passed to our our method we are
going to override to create to get the
samples again out of our our samples
array and we then are going to create a
media description for such a sample
let's have a look in this get media
description method to see that there is
not much magic behind it we see we are
just using a media's description
compared builder and
we populate this data with the data from
our samples and then we built such a
media description compared which we
return to our connector so now we offer
we've already this media session
connector as a next step again we need
to pause the player to the connector so
we can sync the player with the media
session here we again set use the set
player method the first parameter is the
player itself the second parameter is a
playback preparer we are not going to
use it because we don't want to allow
external application to initiate
playback in our sample so that's kind of
it again a non destroy we need to clean
up first we just release the media
session and as a second step we again
set the player instance to null this
time in the connector to avoid leaking
an instance of the player so now that's
kind of it if everything is correct we
should be able to deploy the application
again please switch to the phone again
and Andrew should now be able to use
Android Google assistant to skip to the
next item let's see if this works
play next track
[Music]
why fine well done thank you
and now now over to Andrew again for
downloading in offline functionality
thank you mark if we can switch back to
the slides please
okay so another feature of meteor apps
that I'm sure you're all familiar with
is support for downloading media for
offline playback this is really
important if your users are going to be
in a situation where they have no
connectivity or intermittent
connectivity this has been a much
requested feature for a while now and
we're really pleased that we've been
able to launch this in our two point 8.0
release this week in exoplayer
our support for downloading is built on
top of our support for caching so I'm
going to and say a little bit about how
caching fits into the picture of the
player setup and then we'll look at how
downloading builds on top of that so
this diagram is intended to show you the
data flow when playing one mp3 file we
have a song which is in the cloud
somewhere we have a data source which is
requesting that over HTTP it's loading
the data and then we had a media source
that was getting the information from
there and providing it to the player
let's see how caching fits into this
well it's quite simple we just add a
cache data source that sits in between
the data source we're using for loading
from the network and the media source
that's providing data to the player and
it's going to be responsible in with a
cache instance in this case we're using
a simple cache which is provided by XO
players core library the way this works
is as follows when the media source
requests some data it's going to ask
that ask the cache data source to
provide that information the cache data
source is going to look in the cache if
it's present there then that's great we
can get the data from local storage that
goes to the media source and we never
had to go to the network on the other
hand if the data is not present in the
cache so we've got a cache miss then the
cache data source needs to go to the
data source that's being used to load
from the network and it's going to
request the data from there and then
it's going to store it in the cache when
it arrives and in this way the cache
gradually gets populated with the data
that's loaded while during playback
you can see also on this diagram we've
got a cash Viktor this component is
responsible for making sure that our
cash doesn't grow indefinitely as we
play more and more different media items
okay now let's we want to think about
downloading so downloading is a separate
operation which you might want to
perform in the background so it might
need a service and this downloading
operation what's going on internally is
it's going to read through the entire
stream and as it does that it'll be
populating the same cache instance that
you're using for playback and as you can
probably guess when you do this
operation if you've populated the cache
with all of the data then when it comes
to playback your player is going to be
able to get everything from the cache
from the cache data source there's never
a need to go to the network in this case
one very important thing to note is that
we've got a no op cache of victor so
this is an implementation of cache the
victor which does nothing it's never
going to evict data from the cache the
reason we have that is that we don't
want to have a situation whereby we're
downloading the stream and then when
we've downloaded up to a certain amount
of data we start getting rid of data at
the beginning of the stream because that
would be very annoying for users ok
so that's the theory let's see how this
works in practice if we could switch
back to the laptop please so we're going
to do this in three steps
the first step is we're going to add
support for caching to our player then
we're going to implement an audio
download service which is going to
actually run the download operation as
in the background then finally we're
going to add a very minimal piece of UI
to our activity in order to let us
trigger the downloads to take place okay
so we'll go ahead and create a cache
data source Factory and as we saw on the
slide this is going to sit between our
data source factory for loading from the
network and the media source which is
actually going to be extracting the
media so you can see we're using a
utility method to get our cache and
let's jump into that and see what's
going on there so as I mentioned we're
sharing the same cache for playback and
downloading and that means it's
important that we just have a single
tune for our whole process inside get
cache what we're doing is we check if
we've got one already if we don't have
one we're going to create a file
which is pointing to a directory where
we're going to store the downloads then
we're going to instantiate a simple
cache passing in that directory and also
a no op cache of victor which is very
important because we don't want to be
removing data from the cache okay so
that's how we make a simple cache we
also need to provide the cache data
source factory with the upstream data
source factory for loading data from the
network okay and that's what we need to
instantiate a cached data source factory
let's introduce a local variable for
that and then we're going to use that
cache data source factory in place of
the data source factory we were using
before for loading from the network okay
so hopefully that makes sense for adding
support for caching to our player now
we're going to move on and we're going
to add an audio download service which
is actually going to run the downloading
operation so we provide a superclass
forward called download service for your
for you download services that you'll be
putting in your application so we'll be
inheriting from that here ok so there's
a few things a few steps we need to do
now the most important one important not
to forget is to add a declaration for
the service to your manifest so we're
going to add our audio download service
here now we can switch back and we have
to implement a constructor and three
methods so let's let's start doing that
we'll create a constructor with no
arguments but then we're going to call
the super constructor and pass in some
information about the download
notifications so we'll need a
notification ID which must be different
from the notification ID we used for
audio playback
we'll also pass in an interval and what
at which to update the notification and
we'll just use the default here will
pass in we'll pass in a channel ID for
our download notification channel and
finally we also need to provide a string
resource which describes the
notification channel and that works just
the same as the one we did for audio
playback that had a notification channel
as well now we need to override some
methods so let's have a look at those
the first one is we need to provide a
download manager and we have a utility
method for this which we'll have a look
at in a second
that's just taking a context let's jump
in there
so again we're using a singleton
instance of a download manager for our
whole process this is also creating a
file because it needs to persist some
information about downloads that are in
progress and then we're instantiated a
download manager passing in the same
cache instance as the one that we're
using for the cache during playback you
can see also there's a data source
factory for loading data to populate the
cache and we've also got ADC raliser
for progressive download actions because
we're downloading progressive media ok
for get scheduler for the purposes of
our simple demo app we're just going to
leave this returning null but in a real
application you would want to provide
some kind of job scheduler so that the
system can start your download service
when your process isn't running in order
to resume downloads you can have a look
at our full demo app for an example of
how to do that finally we're going to
provide a progress notification and
we've got a handy utility method to
build one here this is going to take a
context an icon which is going to be
shown in the notification associated
with the download that's in progress and
we'll just use our playback I confer for
that then we'd provide the download
channel ID which is the same one that we
used earlier this one's actually a
string not a resource one one parameter
far ahead ok so we get our download
channel ID for our and we actually need
an intense next which we'll just pass
null for I think we've got a bit mixed
up with the parameters here so if you
remove download channel name oh easily
done there's a lots of parameters ok
then the message is no content intent is
null the message is no and we'll just
pass our task States which has
information about the downloads that are
in progress what their status is whew
that's a lot of parameters ok so that
looks pretty good
that's implementing our download service
the final step I promised is just
providing a way to trigger these
downloads from our activity so as you
can see we've got an empty list view
here we're going to replace that with a
live
samples so we've just got three items in
a playlist when the user taps one of
those we're going to trigger the
download to start and to do that well we
will be creating a progressive download
action if you were downloading a
different type of content like a -
stream then you would not use
progressive download action you'd use
the corresponding download action for
the type of stream you're downloading
that's going to take a URI it's going to
take a flag to say whether we're
removing or not we want to add it to the
cache so we'll pass in false we don't
want to associate any custom data so
we'll pass null for the data and the
custom cache key once we've created our
progressive download action all that
remains is to call a method on the
download service there's a static method
to start the service with that action
and that takes a context which is main
activity doc this not the item click
listener this okay
it takes the class of the download
service which is audio download service
class it takes the download action which
we've just created progressive download
action and finally we can pass Falls for
foreground because our activity is
already in the foreground okay it's
quite a few bits to remember there but
hopefully we've got everything let's
give that a try and see if it works
now we had plans to show you putting the
device into flight mode and playing back
the downloaded content but unfortunately
we're having to use cost to play the
stream so we won't actually be able to
show you the putting the device in
flight mode you'll need to use your
imagination as you can see when we tap
the items you get a little play icon
which is our download notification and
that's going to progress as the download
progresses and that's populating the
cache in the background ok so that's
pretty much it for downloading I'm now
going to hand back over to mark to say a
few words about cost yeah thank you
Andrew so there is a last important
integration we did not cover in code and
we will know coloring code it's the
integration with Google cost Google cost
is almost expected by all users by users
to be supported by media apps we've
recently added a cost extension which
makes integration with cost for
exoplayer
vacation pretty easier let's switch to
the slides again please the cue the cost
extension the costing sanction takes
advantage of the player interface of the
exoplayer library all the UI components
and other components like the player
notification manager the media session
connection which we've seen in action
take advantage of this player interface
and only rely on this player interface
the most prominent implementation of
this player interface is the simple
extra player almost all exoplayer
applications use the simplex a player
for local playback the cost extension
now adds another implementation of this
player interface which is the cost
player the cosplayer wraps the remote
media client of the cost SDK so it gets
pretty easy to swap local playback done
with the simplex a player with remote
playback of the cost player so if
because all those and components of the
exo player library and hopefully also
your application only rely on the player
interface you can exchange this local
playback with remote playback quite
easily you can also have a look at the
cost demo application which we add to
our github repository and we have also a
blog post on media or medium which shows
you how to set up the cost parts for
your application ok great thank you Mark
and so all that remains really is to
provide you with a link to the branch
which has the code that we've written
state or at least it'll be very similar
to the codes we've written today and
please go and check that out and try it
out you'll actually be able to try the
download functionality by putting your
device into flight mode and making sure
that it plays it back which we can't do
now so please check that out we have an
office hours session today at 3:30 and
please come along if you've got
questions and lots of members of the
team will be there and we'd be delighted
to meet you and find out about what
you're doing with extra player and how
we can help you with that this is a link
to our github project if you if you
haven't seen that before we have a
developer guide which takes you through
the process of getting started with EXO
play
at a slightly slower pace and it helps
to explain some of the background and
and finally as Mark alluded to we also
have a blog on medium where members of
the exoplayer team are writing blog
posts about new functionality that we're
working on so please do check that out
and subscribe and with that thank you
very much
[Music]